hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the chess.com Global
Chess Championship Finals uh it is the
quarterfinal match between Anish giri
and temu rajabov and this is their
second match the first match ended by
Anish winning three games were a drawn
uh one game was won by Anisha and this
is now the first game of the second
match and it is quite a nice one so
thank you for suggesting it uh features
the Italian game basically the two
knights of defense and it's very
interesting as Anish has a chessable
course on uh basically E4 and uh well
amongst other things the the Italian uh
game and you can see just how well he
does things when playing the Italian and
it seems like such a such an opening
that is so analyzed where nothing can
happen but here in this game you will
see that the just one slight uh
inaccuracy by black or in this case it's
a huge blunder but it looks like a
slight inaccuracy can lead to a complete
uh downfall so let's dive straight into
it Anish has the white pieces and and he
opens with Pawn to E4 as advertised with
a ponte5 knight F3 Knight to C6 and
Bishop to C4 with Bishop to C5 and now
not the strongest move but Anish goes
for castles we have Knight to F6
transposing into the two knights defense
and now Pawn to D3 we have pawned A6
Pawn to C3 all very very standard moves
here Bishop to A7 and now Pawn to a for
preparing that B4 uh H6 buyer job of and
not Knight B to D2 We have Pawn to D6
and down uh there are some games that
reach this position H3 is a known for
example but here we have Rook T1 by a
niche and it is now as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game and we often
say that in similar positions yes you
have a complete control over this
diagonal and you can put some pressure
with Knight to G4 but it doesn't really
do all that much because white can just
play Rook to do interestingly that's
exactly what demo goes for here uh
Knight the G4 he puts pressure on F2 and
okay now Rook D2 now you will
re-maneuver your pieces Knight F1 ig3
will kick away the at night from this G4
square and then black will waste the
tempo and you will also waste the tempo
when you move your Rook from this weird
E2 square and nothing is really
happening here but it's you know it's
good fun so night stage seven we have
Knights the F1 at night the G6 and now
Knight to G3 we have Castles by Tamer
and now Pawn to H3 getting rid of the
knight from such an active Square Knight
back to F6 and now we have oh instead of
Knight um the F6 you could consider B5
and then let's say something like Bishop
D5 C6 Bishop goes back to B3 and then
you retreat with the Knight to F6 but uh
rajaba does it right away Knight F6 with
Bishop to B3 now getting the bishop out
of Harm's wave of any future advances
with Rook to E8 and now Pawn to D4
usually when you have everything nicely
developed you will finally Advance this
Pawn to D4 uh of course you have to have
your e for Pawn protected to do so uh we
have Bishop to D7 by team or Rook back
to E1 now white Returns the tempo uh
black also Wasted by moving the Knight
to G4 and F6 and now Queen to C8 putting
pressure on that H3 Pawn uh and now
Bishop to E3 and here we have Bishop to
C6 you could also consider something
like C5 or C6 or A5 Bishop to C6 by
Taylor and now Bishop to C2 you have to
guard your E4 Pawn now as the bishop
also helps out with the attack uh Pawn
to A5 trying to stop B4 but Anish
advances it either way because well you
can do it so a captures C captures on B4
and now of course you have to be mindful
B5 might be coming D5 might be coming so
that bishop and C6 might not be all that
great and you could play something like
that should be 7 B5 and then the game
continues however in the game Knight the
F4 was played by arajaba with some ideas
of of going after the attack because the
Bishops are so wonderfully placed uh it
seems like you could be having a bishop
pair from Hell position here also with
the queen coming to H3 the Knight can
enter the game The Rook might be able to
be shifted into the attack very quickly
but the Knight F4 move completely
blunders the game for black but it's up
to you guys to figure out how so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this idea and there is more than one way
to do it so whichever you find will be
will be very nice I have at it
foreign
to do it congratulations on spotting
either of the two plans uh one being uh
Queen to D2 uh or queen to C1 it's just
important to put pressure on the Knight
on F4 and the other one being the brute
forcing e d captures on E5 so
congratulations uh on fighting either
just putting the queen on this diagonal
or going for D captures on E5 and in the
game Queen to D2 was played but I will
just show why this is so strong because
it's very impressive and also
congratulations to everyone who found it
if D captures on E5 you you have to
react to this D captures on E5 Now
You're Gonna Play Bishop captress on A7
Rook captures an A7 uh and now look at
this Knight captures on E5 and it seems
like a move you shouldn't be able to do
because the E5 square is guarded by The
Rook but look at this Rook captures any
five Queen D4 and now both of the Rooks
are hanging uh there is no way to defend
both of them and the white just wins so
what you would have to do here after
Bishop captures an A7 is not captured
but played B6 uh but I mean now it's
just uh you're gonna give up too much
material Bishop capture C capture is
never gonna play Knights to F5 and the
position is already quite winning for
white even if Bishop captures on e4
which seems like a possibility now the
F5 Knight is unguarded look at this Rook
captures Queen captures Rook captures
and E5 opens up a discovery here Queen
back to C8 and now Rook captures Queen
captures Now Pawn to A5 you create a
past Pawn for example captures captures
and it's pretty much equal material only
that white has a past Pawn uh on the a
file and you also have a light Square
Bishop the light Square Bishop can guard
the A8 Square can be also very important
in the long run all in all a winning
position for white but in the game after
Knight F4 Queen to D2 was played it's a
much more interesting line than the one
we've just shown uh and now the point is
you can't just allow Bishop captures
that would just win you the pawn uh so
let's say you go back Knight G6 then
comes the bishop captures on H6 look at
this G captures Queen characters and how
do you prevent Knight F5 Queen to G7
Checkmate you can play Bishop D7 but
still Knight F5 now threatening
Checkmate if Bishop captures spawn
captures the Knight is attacked if the
Knight moves then the F6 Knight hangs uh
this is uh and just game over so uh
rajable has to stick to his plan the
Knight is staying on F4 he plays Pawn to
G5 but now comes with a very nice D
captures on E5 D captures Bishop
captures and A7 wheel captures and now
again Knight to F5 now the H6 spawn has
been weakened so King to H7 and now H4
and is this is this so bad for black uh
yes yes it is here we have Queen to D7
offering a queen trade
but now again one of the reasons why
it's so bad for black to have the Rook
undefended on A7 now you can just uh
decline the queen trade with Tempo not
The Rook on A7 is hanging so B6 and now
you play B5 or you don't have to it's a
nice move to throw in but it's not
necessary Bishop to B7 and Rook 8 to D1
attacking the queen queen to E6 not all
that many moves for the black queen and
not Bishop to B3 uh the black queen is
out of squares
um uh that you can use to defend the
story about that uh she can use the
defend the F7 Pawn so Queen to C8 and
not just the bishop captures on F7
attacking The Rook end there's no good
way to handle this uh one of uh uh one
of the possibilities let's say you move
the Rook uh just eight captures on G5
the Knight is now ready to jump to G5
and if you don't play this place I'm
like Bishop captures on e4 which is
always an option uh removing the
defender of the Knight there's a G6
check and now I have to remove the king
Rook capture 78 Queen captures G7 check
King H7 and now even G8 Queen after
Knight counters you will play Queen
captures on e4 threaten all sorts of
nasty discoveries and once the king
moves let's say Bishop captures Queen
captures Queen captures on E5 and now
after King H7 you just Checkmate the
black king queen E7 checking a chair
Queen F6 checking H7 and queen
characters on H6 will be Checkmate so
just one of the possibilities if you
decide to move the Rook so it's not
possible to move the Rook uh Tamer goes
for Bishop captures on e4 now it's your
last chance to do it but now just Bishop
captures and E8 look at this queen
captures on F5 and now Bishop to D7
beautifully played by aniff trying to
remove one of the Defenders of the E4
bishop and now after Queen to G6 look at
this Knight captures on E5 attacks the
queen on G6 Queen to G7 and now a
spectacular finish Queen captures an E4
just giving up the queen like that this
and it was in this position on move 34
that Timo rajabo resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
our point is that if you don't accept
the queen if you play King h8 then white
is just up a full Rook you can move the
queen anywhere it doesn't really matter
you're up a full Rook uh it's pointless
the even discuss this so after Queen
captures any for what happens if the
queen is accepted Knight captures on e4
now comes the bishop to F5 with check
king castle move somewhere King to G8
Rook the G8 Rook 38 with check now F7
and H7 are taken so the king cannot go
anywhere you have to block with the
queen now you just pick up the queen
Rook captures and f8 King captures and
you eliminate the Knight with Rook
captures on e4 and you're even defending
the A4 Pawn so there is really no point
in continuing this black is down a full
bishop and that's just it
so beautifully played by both of them
but it is uh Anish who who takes the
full point in this one and you can just
see how even though it's possible to
play this white is better here white is
controlling a lot more space here with
uh with many possibilities in The
Possession but after Knight to F4 which
is a move you really want to play in
many of the lines here it just doesn't
work I mean uh beautifully beautifully
explained and now you know as you all
probably play the the Joker piano or you
face the two knights defense quite a lot
so you will have some ideas of what to
do in certain positions because it looks
very scary I mean the bishop here the
bishop here guarding all controlling all
of these diagonals the queen controlling
this diagonal then I don't know for the
other night the The Rook may be coming
into the attack with E6 G6 I mean
there's many uh lines that are scary and
the position certainly hides many
secrets and has a lot of potential but
if it loses it loses and here Anish
shows why why it loses and obviously he
did a lot of work or and put a lot of
work into creating his um adjustable
course on this very topic so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed that the
second match was actually won by yeah
and they played a a tiebreak game which
on each one and then uh Anish is the one
who advances into the semi-finals uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it if you if you enjoy uh you
know studying uh uh so many lines of the
Italian game of the tournaments defense
then you probably found this very useful
and you will be able to employ it in
your own games
uh once again really hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Jack obey marovo
Martin
and subramanian for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this uh fine
event uh and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day